schlingerkurs in syrien nach dem abzug
aus dem norden des landes verlegen die
usa jetzt neue truppen in den osten sie
sagen um die ölfelder zu sichern
schwere vorwürfe gegen boeing
indonesische ermittler führen in ihrem
abschlussbericht eine ganze fehlerserie
auf die zum absturz einer 737 max führte
und schluss mit den klettertouren der
für die australischen aborigines heilige
berg uluru darf nicht mehr bestiegen
werden
nachrichten nicht da das heute mit
christian sievers eingebunden abend
hinein geben sie uns 20 minuten wir
haben für sie den überblick über diesen
nachrichten freitag
kristin otto hat den sport im blick
hallo und gelernte es ist ein hin und
her in einer hochbrisanten gegend die
usa wollen jetzt neue truppen nach
syrien schicken die rede ist offenbar
auch von kampfpanzern und zwar um die
ölfelder dort unter kontrolle zu halten
das kommt überraschend weil präsident
donald trump ja gerade dabei ist seine
truppen aus dem norden von syrien
abzuziehen ist das jetzt kommando zurück
gucken wir auf die karte das zentrum der
syrischen ölindustrie liegt im osten des
landes vor allem an zwei standorten in
der provinz deir essor ist eines der
größten ölfelder von syrien an seinem
stern berichtet kampfgebiet und öl
gebiet der osten von syrien vor gerade
einmal zwei wochen sind die amerikaner
größtenteils abgezogen wollten nichts
mehr zu tun haben mit den blutigen
kämpfen jetzt plötzlich könnten sie
zurückkommen zum schutz der ölfelder
twittert der präsident wir werden die
ölfelder niemals einem neuformierten es
überlassen so trump sein
verteidigungsminister erklärt am
nachmittag die usa werden in syrien
präsent sein um zu verhindern dass der
öl einnahmen bekommt das syrische öl bei
der tatsächlich hatte der sogenannte
islamische staat in der vergangenheit
hier ölfelder besetzt geld verdient für
den terror jetzt aber so experten seines
kämpfer davon weit entfernt
es gibt nach wie vor kämpfer des
islamischen staates im osten syriens
aber die wäre nicht mehr in der lage
größere territorien zu besetzen auch
nicht die ölfelder im osten syriens es
ist also eine schutzbehauptung der
amerikaner diese gebiete schützen zu
wollen vor dem islamischen staat in
erster linie geht es darum territorium
zu besetzen im wettbewerb mit russland
um die zukunft syriens
russland erklärte bereits man sei
besorgt über das hin und her in der us
politik für syrien berichten zufolge
könnten die amerikaner schnell mit
hunderten soldaten zurückkehren denn es
sind noch us truppen
im irak ist wäre eine kehrtwende die
amerikaner fordern die kurden auf an
ihrer seite an seite der amerikaner
dieses gebiet im osten syrien zu sichern
aber gerade erst haben die amerikaner
die kurden verraten also das ist eine
sehr unübersichtliche gemengelage wenn
die amerikaner jetzt ernst machen könnte
das also wieder eine neue lage schaffen
in kriegs und macht chaos in syrien
einiges an hin und her also noch mal
reden im at wissen ist unser mann in
washington immer guten abend ist das
jetzt noch gezielte politik in syrien
mit einer dahinter liegenden
möglicherweise versteckten taktik oder
schlicht das was herauskommt wenn ein
us-präsident die strategische lage nicht
versteht
es ist eine mischung aus beidem also
präsident schon geht es in allererster
linie momentan darum seine
wahlkampfversprechen vom letzten mal
einzulösen weil er sich eben wieder im
wahlkampf befindet und das bedeutet
abzug amerikanischer truppen aus den
konfliktgebieten dieser welt dazu will
er gar keine berater haben er macht das
einfach und diese berater sind dann in
den tagen nach der entscheidung hier
hinter uns im weißen haus aufgeschlagen
allen voran sein enger vertrauter
senator lindsey graham aus dem kongress
er hat ihm auf einer landkarte sehr
genau geschildert wohl die ölfelder
liegen so ist zu hören und hat vor allen
dingen gewarnt dass diese ölfelder in
die hand fallen könnten des iran oder
des syrischen regimes die eng
miteinander kooperieren
das würde bedeuten dass dann eben die
gesamte iran-politik die
sanktionspolitik dadurch unterlaufen
werden könnte
und auf dieser basis beruht ganz
offenbar die entscheidung es geht also
gar nicht in erster linie um den es geht
eher darum das sanktionsregime gegen den
iran unter syrische regime aufrecht zu
erhalten
die analyse live aus washington immer
herzlichen dank und damit nach
deutschland 16 tage nach dem anschlag in
halle mit zwei toten besuch der
präsident des jüdischen weltkongresses
ronald lauder die stadt und die synagoge
die organisation vertritt die jüdischen
gemeinden weltweit halle sei ein weckruf
sagte lauda
deutschland müsse sich fragen lassen ob
es sich wirklich von seiner schwierigen
vergangenheit
gelöst habe aus halle berichtet jan
fritsche sein besuch wurde bis zuletzt
geheim gehalten die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen hoch der
präsident des jüdischen weltkongresses
vor der synagoge in halle an dem ort wo
ein 27-jähriger ein blutbad anrichten
und möglichst viele juden töten wollte
der weltweit höchste vertreter der
jüdischen diaspora will sich selbst ein
bild machen die gemeinde treffen seine
botschaft es gab schon viele worte
jetzt müssen taten folgen wir müssen
gegen hassrede vorgehen und die polizei
muss uns dauerhaft schützen
was wundert leider besonders beunruhigt
der seit jahren verbreitete
antisemitismus in deutschland laut einer
neuen studie des jüdischen
weltkongresses vertritt jeder vierte
hierzulande antisemitische ansichten
selbst unter top verdienern mit
hochschulabschluss seines 18 prozent als
antisemitisch gilt in der studie zb
juden gegenüber ablehnend eingestellt zu
sein oder zu glauben juden hätten zu
viel macht in wirtschaft oder regierung
vergangenen freitag hatten sich die
innenminister von bund und ländern auf
einen zehn punkte plan geeinigt gegen
antisemitismus und rechtsradikalismus
darunter mehr schutz für synagogen und
ein schärferes waffenrecht für lauda ein
erster schritt neben der politik nimmt
er aber auch die zivilgesellschaft in
die pflicht
60 prozent der pripro 61 prozent der
deutschen wären bereit auf die straße zu
gehen von wie hier in halle den juden
beizustehen
das sind die guten leute die müssen
aufstehen und sich mehr zeigen
except bildungsziele viele hallenser
haben sich schon gezeigt auch hier am
zweiten tatort vor dem döner imbiss ist
die anteilnahme bis heute deutlich
sichtbar
in thüringen ist übermorgen wahl und es
wird spannend
der einzige linke ministerpräsident in
deutschland bodo ramelow will sein amt
verteidigen aber es könnte für seine rot
rot grüne koalition eng werden
das zeigt das neue zdf politbarometer
wenn heute wahl wäre käme die cdu auf 26
die linke auf 28 prozent die spd auf 9
die afg bekäme 21 prozent grüne und fdp
könnten mit sieben beziehungsweise fünf
prozent rechnen weil keine partei mit
der afg zusammengehen will heißt das die
bildung einer neuen regierung wird
schwierig andreas postel unterstützung
von gregor gysi braucht bodo ramelow
eigentlich gar nicht beim
wahlkampfabschluss auf dem erfurter
anger 54 prozent der thüringer wünschen
sich derzeit bodo ramelow als
ministerpräsident und der würde die rot
rot grüne koalition gerne fortsetzen
alle in deutschland haben gedacht das
geht gar nicht und mit einer stimme
mehrheit schon gerade gar nicht und
deswegen haben wir jetzt erfolgreich
gezeigt es geht und wir hätten gerne da
wir gute umfragewerte haben
das gibt bürger auch sich entscheiden
und sagen wenn wir schon die arbeit gut
finden dann wäre es auch freundlich wenn
man das kreuzchen bei rot-rot-grün markt
die linke stark aber die partner
schwächeln die spd seit wochen
einstellig braucht zum
wahlkampfabschluss in gera mehr als
musikalische unterstützung wolfgang
tiefensee fällt es nicht leicht den
eigenen anteil an der thüringer
regierungsbilanz rüberzubringen
der bundestrend macht ihnen zu schaffen
wir brauchen eine starke spd in einer
rot-rot-grünen regierung das ist die aus
balancierende die stabilisierende kraft
in den letzten fünf jahren gewesen und
mit unseren drei ressorts finanzen
wirtschaft und inneres haben wir sehr
gute arbeit geleistet
cdu-herausforderer mike mohring ist da
ganz anderer meinung bis zum schluss auf
marktplätzen kämpfen gerade auch in
kleinen orten das ist auch die strategie
der cdu
denn die vielen unentschlossenen könnten
bei den vorausgesagt knappen mehrheiten
alles noch verändern
über kämpfen um jede stimme weil es im
stabile verhältnisse für thüringen geht
und da bin ich ganz zuversichtlich dass
das gelingt wenn zu viele unentschlossen
sind dann wissen alle es geht um die
zukunft unseres landes es geht nicht um
berlin
es geht um thüringen jeder entscheidet
mit seiner stimme für eine stabile
regierung in thüringen eine koalition
mit der afg hat er ausgeschlossen
das klima im wahlkampf ist diesmal
deutlich rauer auch wegen büren heute
fast überall gegendemonstrationen wo der
afg spitzenkandidat auftritt der
verfassungsschutz stuft seinen völlig
nationalen flügel als verdachtsfall ein
für ein interview steht uns nicht zur
verfügung holen wir uns unser land
zurückholen wir die anlehnung an die
wände an die friedliche revolution vor
30 jahren stört besonders auch bündnis
90 grüne
sie haben in thüringen ihre wurzeln in
der bürgerbewegung wollen die rot rot
grüne koalition fortsetzen
klimaschutz und demokratie das sind die
großen themen von bündnis 90/die grünen
und wer will dass rot-rot-grün
fortgesetzt wird mit einer starken
umweltministerin beispielsweise an der
spitze der muss am sonntag bei bündnis
90 die grünen sein kreuz machen
viel wird davon abhängen ob die fdp mit
spitzenkandidat thomas kemmerich den
einzug in den landtag schafft über 30
prozent der wahlberechtigten sind noch
unentschlossen besonders um diese
stimmen geht es jetzt beim
wahlkampfendspurt in thüringen
unser nächstes thema es reicht von
eindeutigen blicken über zweideutige
bemerkungen bis hin zu sexueller gewalt
die antidiskriminierungsstelle des
bundes hat eine repräsentative umfrage
unter berufstätigen zum thema sexuelle
übergriffe veröffentlicht und danach
sind die allermeisten betroffenen frauen
besonders viele im gesundheitsbereich
einzelheiten jetzt von cornelia strauß
im büro im restaurant oder im
krankenhaus unerwünschte
grenzüberschreitungen gibt es offenbar
an jedem arbeitsplatz wie die jüngste
studie zu dem thema ergab geht sexuelle
belästigung am arbeitsplatz größtenteils
von männern aus es geht darum dass
dagegen gute strategien entwickelt
werden aber es geht auch darum dass wir
die öffentlichkeit sensibilisieren dafür
dass diese dinge sexuelle belästigung am
arbeitsplatz eben kein kavaliersdelikt
ist sondern dass das dinge sind die bis
zu den straftatbeständen gehen die
belästigungen sind in erster linie
verbaler art 62 prozent aller befragten
haben unangemessene kommentare gehört
vielen sind auch belästigende gesten
intime fragen oder auch unerwünschte
berührungen bekannt diese erfahrungen
machen vor allem beschäftigte im
gesundheitswesen die
gleichstellungsbeauftragte des berliner
uniklinikum charité bestätigt die
ergebnisse der studie belästigende sind
weniger die kollegen als personen von
außen wie kunden oder patienten im
pflegebereich sind es hauptsächlich die
situationen wo ihnen behandlungen zu
kommen müssen und sie sich und lösen
müssen da wird natürlich auch gesehen
dass hier sehr offen
der umgang sein muss und dann werden
teilweise auch chancen gesehen das
auszunutzen
die charité hat für ihre etwa 18.000
beschäftigten eine beschwerdestelle
eingerichtet eine maßnahme zu der alle
betriebe gesetzlich verpflichtet sind
von der aber viele beschäftigte nicht
wissen
die antidiskriminierungsstelle des
bundes sieht unternehmen in der pflicht
beschäftigte besser aufzuklären und zu
schützen
seit heute ist es offiziell der absturz
der indonesischen passagiermaschine vom
typ boeing 737 max vor einem jahr ist
auf eine verkettung von fehlern zurück
zu
wartungsprobleme und wenig training der
crew massiv in der kritik steht die
herstellerfirma boeing der die ermittler
in ihrem abschlussbericht
konstruktionsfehler vorwerfen 189
passagiere waren damals ums leben
gekommen britta jäger mit einzuhalten
anton saha die hat durch den absturz der
leyen air maschine in indonesien zwei
angehörige verloren
von dem abschlussbericht der ermittler
ist er enttäuscht
meiner meinung nach ist diese
untersuchung noch nicht abgeschlossen
weil der bericht nicht eindeutig benennt
wer genau die schuld trägt fast ein
ganzes jahr haben sie ermittelt und
sprechen nun von einer ganzen
pannenserie die den absturz der boeing
737 max verursacht hatte hauptgrund aber
sei ein fehler im steuerungssystem mks
gewesen
das system das von einem einzigen sensor
abhängt bestimmt die richtung der
flugzeugnase dieser sensor beeinflusst
also das ganze system
es sorgt dafür dass die nase des
flugzeugs bei einem strömungsabriss
automatisch nach unten gedrückt wird
doch der sensor lieferte falsche daten
weder im handbuch noch beim training
waren die piloten darauf vorbereitet
worden
mit dem bericht kassiert boeing nun ein
weiteres vernichtendes urteil
bereits anfang oktober hatte eine
unabhängige kommission in den usa dem
flugzeugbauer und der amerikanischen
flugsicherheitsbehörde faa schwere
schlampereien im zulassungsverfahren der
maschine bescheinigt boeing war als
unternehmen eine großartige
erfolgsgeschichte
ich glaube nicht dass sie langfristig
dadurch ko gehen werden aber die firma
hat ein ernsthaftes problem
noch immer gilt ein weltweites
startverbot für die 737 max boeing
verspricht technische probleme zu lösen
und piloten besser zu schulen
46 opferfamilien wollen boeing vor
gericht zur verantwortung ziehen
die prozesse werden jahre dauern
ganz anderes thema jetzt ein
einzigartiger berg wir kennen ihn hier
in europa als ayers rock er heißt in der
sprache der ureinwohner unruh und er
zählt zu den beliebtesten touristen
zielen von australien jedes jahr kommen
zigtausende hierher um zu staunen oder
den 348 meter hohen felsen zu besteigen
für die ureinwohner ein frevel denn der
berg ist für sie heilig und seit heute
sind klettertouren dort verboten mehr
von normen odenthal
der morgen beginnt traumhaftes
besinnlich doch damit ist es bald vorbei
schlange stehen an einem tag für
australiens geschichtsbuch sie hier sind
die letzten touristen die den uluru
besteigen werden besteigen dürfen
das stand schon lange auf meiner liste
mir ist ziemlich egal was andere leute
an den berg bedeutend finden
ich will einfach darauf und das mache
ich auch tut mir nur leid für alle
anderen die das nicht mehr können
respekt darum geht's die ureinwohner
verehren diesen berg ein mystischer ort
der nicht betreten werden soll dafür
kämpfen sie seit jahrzehnten und jetzt
ist es soweit die touristen sagen das
sei ihr ärger aber das stimmt nicht
er gehört uns ureinwohnern für uns ist
der uhu heilig und so muss er behandelt
und geschützt werden als heiligt die
bitte nicht hochzuklettern gab es schon
lange und half nicht jetzt also das
verbot die letzte chance war heute wohl
ein besonderer kitzel aber nicht jeder
ist die ihn erleben
ich wollte unbedingt hoch und waren wir
im kulturzentrum und haben uns
informiert über das leben der aborigines
und auch über das heiligtum und mit
respekt auf dieses heiligtum habe ich
mich dagegen entschieden
das klettern auf den uluru war nie ohne
37 menschen haben dabei ihr leben
verloren
auch diese gefahr ist nun gebannt in
kalifornien brennen riesige waldgebiete
starke winde treiben die flammen bis in
die vororte von los angeles und san
francisco rund 50.000 menschen sind dort
auf der flucht den feuerwehren gelingt
es bisher nicht die brände unter
kontrolle zu bekommen
einige ortschaften mussten deshalb
geräumt werden wegen erhöhter
brandgefahr wurde in teilen des
bundesstaates der strom abgestellt
immer wieder solche bilder aus
kalifornien
und jetzt kommt der sport christ heute
wieder fußball kein berauschender europa
league abend für die deutschen vereine
aber immerhin ohne niederlage borussia
mönchengladbach und der vfl wolfsburg
spielten jeweils auswärts unentschieden
eintracht frankfurt erkämpfte sich zu
hause einen sieg gegen standard lüttich
2 abwehrspieler springen in die bresche
bei frankfurt sind wichtige
offensivkräfte verletzt da werden
standards spiel entscheidend und leute
wie abraham der am langen pfosten
gelauert hat erst freistoß von links
dann ecke von rechts diesmal ist
hinteregger da zwei zu null
die eintracht kann europa league das ist
inzwischen bekannt
wichtiger sieg extrem tut es extrem gut
dass man jetzt mal da stehen wo wir
stehen
trainer adi hütter wohnt es dennoch das
nötig durch an allah noch verkürzen kann
das gegentor konnte im direkten
vergleich um platz zwei in der gruppe
wichtig werden
frankfurts fans dürfen zudem nicht zum
rückspiel nach lüttich reisen als strafe
für verfehlungen die bundesliga ist so
spannend wie selten nur zwei punkte
trennen die ersten neun vereine große
erfolgsdruck lastet auf borussia
dortmund im revier derby auf schalke
den größten druck ist derzeit lucia
fahrer ausgesetzt
dennoch wohl seinem team nach dem sieg
über den spitzenreiter aus
mönchengladbach nur ein punkt zur
tabellenführung fehlt wird der trainer
von der ständigen kritik sichtlich
angeschlagen
es ist heutzutage so momentan ja es ist
so was können wir machen die schalker
dagegen sind nach erneut starker
leistung bei der unverdienten niederlage
in hoffenheim auf einer abstimmung
mäßigen hof ja vorfreude klar extremst
sogar es ist jetzt natürlich auch mein
erstes in der bundesliga und als trainer
sind dementsprechend morgen geht's los
und wir können es kaum erwarten
auch die dortmunder können es kaum
erwarten das große derby das über des
trainers schicksal entscheiden wird
genau alles dazu morgen im aktuellen
spiel ende oktober warm und sonnig
geht's morgen durch den tag zumindest
für die meisten details beim wetter hat
gleich osten telli für 22 uhr empfehle
ich ihnen den kollegen claus kleber und
das heute-journal und morgen freut sich
barbara hahlweg an dieser stelle auf sie
von uns allen danke fürs zuschauen und
hinein in einen angenehmen freitagabend
ein stück beamte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ein ziemlich warm attacke
erwartet uns morgen aus dem südwesten
europas kommt die warme luft und dieses
hoch her
das erwärmt die luft weiter aber die
kalte luft liegt schon auf der lauer und
kommt spitzen am sonntag von nordwesten
her nach deutschland rein schauen wir in
die nacht im nordwesten deutschlands
viele wolken und regen teils stürmische
böen sonst ist es ruhig an den alpen
stern klar und dort wird es dann auch am
kältesten mit 3 grad im westen sind es
13 grad morgen im tagesverlauf löst sich
der nebel im süden allmählich aufnahm
wird hier immer sonniger in der mitte
gibt es auch sonnige abschnitte aber
viele wolken nach norden hin sind die
wolken noch dichter an der nordsee
wieder regen teils sturmböen aus südwest
temperaturen im osten bis 21 grad im
süden bis 22 sonst liegen wir mit 15 bis
20 grad durchaus im recht warmen bereich
für ende oktober
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage
sonntag bis 22 grad warm aber von
nordwesten her kommt die abkühlung teils
mit regen montag und dann dienstag vor
allem ziemlich kühl bei sechs bis zwölf
grad und das sind die höchstwerte damit
ein schöner abend